there was a delightful confrontation on
Fox News yesterday between Fox News
anchor Harris Faulkner and Democratic
but very right-leaning Senator Joe
manchin now the the thing going on with
Joe manchin is absolutely beautiful
Joe manchin is a guy that is not a
particular friend to the Democratic
party on many important issues but every
once in a while Joe manchin is a
Democrat and he will vote with the
Democratic majority and in this
particular case Joe manchin announced
that he's supporting the inflation
reduction act the inflation reduction
act does a whole bunch of different
things it doesn't change the level of
Taxation uh on income tax for Americans
but right-wingers have been flipping out
number one because they claim oh it's
going to increase taxes on everybody and
number two they're flipping out on Joe
manchin because they started to think
sorry I punched my mic they started to
think Mansion is a friend of Republicans
and to some degree he is but it's not
always the case and all of a sudden they
are hammering Joe manchin this interview
was absolutely hilarious Harris Faulkner
increasingly incensed with Joe manchin
let's look at some of the moments from
the this interview we got to know the
bottom line on taxes let me tell you the
bottom line on that hair so you want to
know the bottom line the joint committee
on taxation
that opinion was only written by my
friends on the Republican side it was
not done by the whole joint committee so
that is unfair too so let's be accurate
what we're doing here the bottom line is
how any world can you be raising taxes
when all we're saying is the wealthiest
corporations in America 55 of them pay
zero to help this great country of ours
to defend ourselves well how does this
change that because that that's that's
part of the minimum 15 structuring it's
a minimum of 15 the tax rate was at 35
percent before 2017. then it went to 21
that was a tremendous savings but that's
not good enough I guess all we're saying
is at 15 minimum everyone in West
Virginia I know and most people around
the country pay a 21 Corporate or
greater so why can't the greatest
billion dollars of Revenue a year why
can't they pay at least 15 percent for
this great country Now understand
they're talking about a 15
minimum tax on corporations but
Republicans are pretending that this is
an increase to personal income taxes
it's not
because this is
the part that counts
they have complete departments trying to
come up with ways to to find loopholes
and and to keep and to hire people as
well I mean let's not forget that too
um but four hundred thousand dollars was
supposed to be the cutoff and I'm
reading and I am reading Senator this is
below any taxes who's paying any taxes
that doesn't have a corporation that has
revenue of over a billion dollars a year
not one person not one person Harris
you're assuming because they'll pass
that on the companies are paying zero no
no they have asking a different question
than you're answering I'm saying
Americans four hundred thousand dollars
and Below now are going to be taxed
their taxes
that is a pure outright lie now good I'm
not a fan of mansion you guys know I
don't see these people as black and
white
I don't get shocked all of a sudden when
Mansion says something reasonable or
then all of a sudden he's voting with
Republicans that we know who he is he's
a very right-leaning Democrat but here
he's doing a very good job taxes are not
going to go up not at all and you know
one thing how about the people that are
going to be saving as far as on their
Medicare 288 billion dollars who are
paying higher prices than he should
aren't they they didn't even assume that
in the revaluation they didn't talk
about any of that how about if gasoline
prices go down because we're producing
more oil to make more gas those are
going to fluctuate okay so Harris
Faulkner starts getting agitated to
different degrees and then eventually uh
Mansion just has to tell her that she's
telling lies I'm saying
I'm Sarah comes four hundred thousand
dollars and Below now are going to be
attacked their taxes are gonna go up
that's a lie that is a pure outright lie
so their taxes are not going to go up
not at all and you know one thing how
about the people that are going to be
saving as far as on their Medicare too
yeah so repeating that it is just a flat
out a lie uh then she pulls up a uh
segment of mansion speaking to Chuck
Todd and then tries to hammer him on
that and she increasingly desperate
during this conversation I haven't
that wasn't dodgeball that's not a
dodgeball then I'm not getting involved
in the political this is not a political
piece of legislation this is an American
legislation we need energy we need to
pay down debt we need to accelerate our
our permitting process so we can build
things and meet the elections are going
to need some
helpful to make a statement is like as
low as congresses
are you kidding services in the Bible
that's what we do her father served and
service is in the Bible that's her
reaction when Mansion says Harris you
sound mad we're going to do something
good and she goes my father served and
it's in the Bible but how is that even
an answer I know how it's an answer
because there's a contingent and a lot
of them watch Fox News where they
believe
if you are a veteran then of course you
always necessarily want everything
that's best for the country there's no
guarantee of that and if you're a
Christian you always necessarily want
everything that's best for the country
but there's no guarantee of that either
serve our fellow man and woman that's
exactly what I'm doing don't don't
exactly don't make this personal because
it's not I'm simply asking that you've
got a president who can't really help
anybody on the campaign trail with the
numbers he's rocking right now how do
you say something like that it doesn't
sound supportive of your own party and
I'm asking you just say this I'm working
with what I have here in the majority
party that we have is a Democratic party
I'm working with a president who's
accepted the proposal I've put forward
in negotiated which is a balanced energy
policy that's wonderful for our country
I know people who don't like the prison
or don't like Democrats might be upset
this is not about whether you like the
president or whether you like Democrats
do you like so as you can see Harris
Faulkner is just desperate to attack
whatever and whoever she can but the
truth is on this particular Bill Mansion
is correct the Bill's been scored it
looks like like it will reduce inflation
this is what the Republicans claim to
want to do and they just can't accept
that they just can't accept that here's
just one more quick clip that's a lie
that is a pure outright lie so their
taxes are not going to go up not at all
and you know one thing how about the
people that are going to be and you know
what we already played this clip so
we're gonna skip it all right so bottom
line
depending on your perspective there are
people who now are angry with Joe
manchin and then there are people who
now are thrilled with Joe manchin the
reality is that there's sort of like a
grab your popcorn element to this
of wow what who's gonna flip out on
Mansion next and now it's Fox anchor
Harris Faulkner who's very triggered I
don't care about that so much as this is
another reminder
sometimes the these are just people
they're not all good they're not all bad
Mansion is a guy that is way to my right
but every once in a while and it could
be for self-centered reasons we don't
yet fully understand I mean it sounds
like there's going to be some more
domestic oil production Mansion likes
that yeah we could we it's potentially
just from his selfishness and what's in
it for me attitude that he's supporting
this bill but he's supporting a bill
that's going to do some good things and
it's going to it's believed that it will
lower inflation and now Republicans are
just absolutely flipping out on him
let's take a more measured uh approach
this is a guy who is to the right of me
and many in in the audience but he's
doing the right thing now and that's
something we can all be happy about